in sudan's capital cartoon and nearby
city of amdurman reports of intense
military activity and closure of the
main bridge across the river nile
according to government media the coup
plotters were trying to take over the
state media building
the military said measures were being
taken to contain the situation
news of the attempted coup first broke
on state media which sought to reassure
the public
the failed coup attempt clearly
indicates that it's necessary to reform
the military and security apparatuses it
calls for all-out reconsideration of the
transition process and the necessity to
forge a partnership based on the values
and principles of the revolution towards
a civil democratic transition only
a military official says an unspecified
number of soldiers from the ahmed corps
were behind the coup attempt and many
had been arrested and will be
interrogated
hours later traffic appeared to be
flowing smoothly in central cartoon
including around army headquarters
despite any security forces closing the
main bridge across the nile connecting
cartoon to mdurman
sudan has been on a fragile path to
democratic rule since its long-time
ruler umar al-bashir was removed from
power by the army in april 2019
following four months of protests the
country is now ruled by a joint civilian
and military government
it doesn't seem that this is a
transitional government because there
aren't there aren't any steps taking to
uh put together a law for the elections
or a law for the political parties uh
the census hasn't been done uh the
gerrymandering uh for the electoral body
hasn't been
designed so it seems that
even the public is now very furious
the coup attempt is not the first
challenge to the transitional
authorities they say they are foiled or
detected previous ones linked to
factions loyal to bashir
an added sense of insecurity in a nation
already facing high inflation and
shortages of goods and services
mohammed al jazeera